[موسيقى]
يحضرونه جيدا ويحتفلون به في كرنفالين
يجوب ارجاء المنطقه وبعد ساعات من
الاحتفالات يطبخونه وياكلنه
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من
عالم غريب
هنا
تقليد غريب يقوم به المزارعون فبجانب
عملهم في الزراعه يربي هؤلاء قطعان
الخنازير لكن احد الرؤوس من بينها سيكون
الاوفر حظا او ربما الادعس حيث يتم اطعام
هذا الحيوان وتسمينه وتقديم عنايه فائقه
ومركزه له والهدف جعله اكبر وزنا وحجما
بقدر الامكان لتحضيره لاحتفالات يوم
الخنزير الاكبر حيث ياتون بالخنزير الفائز
باللقب بالاحتفال به وسط طقوس معينه هذه
المشاهد تعود الاحتفال في عام 2021 وهذا
الخنزير كان الاكبر في تايوان حيث بلغ
وزنه 1000 كلغ وهو اكبر خنزير يسجل في
تايوان يقوم الواطنون هنا بتحضير الخنزير
جيدا يحملونه اولا ثم يجولون به في ارجاء
القريه ما يقرب من عشرين رجلا تعاونوا
لرفع الخنزير الضخم على الشاحنه لنقله من
مزرعته الى معبد في القريه لتتم مباركته
وتحضيره لمصيره الاخير حيث يطبخ ويوزع
لحمه
[موسيقى]
شامبو
هنا احتفالات اخرى تعود لعام
1998 هذا الخنزير هنا بلغ وزنه
961 كيلو جراما وكان الاكبر انذاك يومها
تهافت السكان المحليون لاقتراب منه
والتبرك به ايمانا منهم لان الخنازير
الكبيره مقدسه
لجعل الخنازير ثقيله الوزن عليهم منعها من
الحركه وتقديم الكثير من الطعام لذلك
ابتكروا طريقه خاصه لتربيه الخنازير تتمثل
بتقييدها في قفص صغير حتى لا يكون لديها
سبير للحركه يمكنها فقط فتح افواهها للاكل
كما ان هناك نوعا من التغذيه القصريه
منظمات حقوق الحيوان في تايلاند اتهمت هذه
المعابد التي تقود احتفالات الخنازير
بمعامله حيوانات بسوء كبير وتعريضها لاقصى
انواع التعذيب من خلال اطعامها قصرا وفتح
افواهها واجبارها على الاكل ومنعها من
الحركه تماما لكن مسؤولين عن الاحتفالات
نفو هذه الاتهامات وطالبوا المنظمات
بالتوقف عن نشر الادعاءات الكاذبه حسب
وصفهم